alright everyone welcome to my python 3
specifically python33 though it should
work with pretty much anything
throughout python 3
series
for any of you guys or girls who are new
to programming i will just say that
learning to program has been
easily one of the best life choices of
mine definitely in the top three
uh it's just giving me so many options
in life and really my freedom to do what
i want so i do these videos because i
hope that i can help other people get to
the point
like that i really feel like
at least these days knowing how to
program is a lot like having a
superpower it sounds kind of funny but
it really is it gives you the ability to
create things pretty much you know
seemingly from nothing and do it pretty
fast
so especially with things like data
analysis and all that as well it puts
you ahead of pretty much everyone else
that isn't using it because they're
using excel or whatever
i really see it as a superpower it
definitely falls under the categories of
a superpower so uh let me pass on this
superpower
so now for some of you guys um
you're probably well i imagine a lot of
people are coming here having never used
python
or programming at all that's not a big
deal this this series at least the
introductory and basics
is geared towards somebody completely
new to programming in python and all of
that but i do expect some python
especially 2.7 users or other versions
of two
sadly maybe even one um and i also know
a lot of people that watch my tutorials
do it at the same time as they're taking
classes and many times those classes
have you using python 2 not python 3.
one of my buddies just told me that here
in 2014 his class is actually using
python 2.5
since um i guess it's a lot of effort
for them to update the coursework
i'm not really sure sure
why and i'm doing my best to not uh be
so lazy since my channel did also start
off as 2-7 and here i am trying my best
to update it to 3-3
so um
while i'm trying to do that i also
realize that people will have indeed
reasons to have multiple versions uh
luckily by this time there are a few
nifty ways to handle
at least using python 2 and python 3
together on the same machine
uh they can even work with each other um
so i'm going to cover that as well so
both how to like run python 2 7 and 3 3
scripts
so i can execute them as well as
actually edit them in idle and work in
their specific environments in idle so
anyways enough on that let's go ahead
and get python 3.3 so to get it you're
going to head to python.org it's up
there in the navbar hopefully you guys
can type that out
then you'll come down here to download
and that's what you're going to want to
click on here
now eventually
um well i don't see it here but if you
if you do look at the home page um
python 3.4 beta
one and two are actually already out so
it's conceivable that relatively soon
python 3.4 will um be joining us and if
during this series i imagine it might
even you know come out in full so uh if
that happens i will just switch to three
four usually the the differences betw
between python three three and three
four especially for a beginner's uh
introductory tutorial
they won't change anything so if by the
time you're watching this you're you
know they've got a three four three five
three six as long as python three uh
it's highly unlikely that any of these
like basic uh introductory
topics are gonna change in the slightest
so
go ahead and download the most recent
version of three
so
um
anyway so what you're gonna do is you
come down to the downloads here for me
it's three three so you wanna download
whatever version you have uh by default
like if you download like let's say this
version here
uh that's gonna download 32-bit this
will download your 64-bit um and and so
on so i i would recommend that you get
64-bit if you
have a 64-bit operating system
just because 32-bit is limited to 2
gigabytes of memory uh so it's useful to
be able to pass that sometimes so
anyways um go ahead and click on
whichever one is yours this one will be
mine
and let it go ahead and download and
whenever it's done uh we'll install so i
would suggest you just pause it because
i'm going to cancel this download so
i've already downloaded it
so pause the video until you're done and
then we'll continue on with the
installation
so once you've completed the download i
don't know wherever you saved it
go ahead and open that up and run it
and you can choose what you want to do
i'm just going to install it for all
users you hit next it's going to ask you
where you want to install it i would
just leave it there
next next
and wait for it to install
and you're all set so whenever that's
done you can hit finish
now i will say that at least me i have
two versions right i've got
both python 27 and 33 running on my
machine and actually i have scripts
that must run
um
two seven like they're written in two
seven and i just have not ported them to
three three yet so i want them to
continue uh being able to run so the
question is how do you do something like
that so the first thing i'll show you
guys is the most basic and that's going
to be what you need to put at the top of
the script to make sure they execute and
this is only for when you install in the
order of
python
2 and then after that you installed
python 3 on top of python 2.
as far as i know someone can can let me
know but in order to go from
python let's say you installed python 3
and then you later decide to install
python 2. it's actually really hard to
get python 3 to run i've you can get it
in kind of a finicky way and i think you
can just change like registry keys or
something
but for the for the purposes here um
i've installed python 2 first then
python 3 and that seems to be the best
way to go about having both installed on
your machine so anyways let's continue
on
and i'll show you guys now how to
run both versions
so what i've gone ahead and done is i've
got two scripts here uh let me just pull
this over here now
uh what i've got here is i've got run
two seven and run three three
and so
uh let me go ahead and edit a couple of
these so this one a couple of these both
of them
i'll just add them both at the same time
multitasking so as you can see at the
top of the script
if you're familiar with
programming this is like your shebang
line right so generally if you're on
something like it's not really too
necessary if you're on windows but if
you're on something like
linux
and you want to be able to execute
python from the command line without
actually saying
um you know python in front of it uh so
if you're like running a cron or
something like that what you would do is
you would give the path to python like
you know user bin environment python
um but for the purposes here what we're
actually going to do is we're telling
python like which version of python we
want to run and this comes with python
3. so this is why if you install python
3 then python 2
i think it's your environment variable
that gets edited and so this actually
won't do anything for you if you install
in that order but if you install in
python 2 then python 3 you'll get this
functionality so and i'm not positive it
comes like so if you if you're running
like let's say python 3 1 or something
i'm not positive that functionality is
there yet i think it came later like
after the first version of python 3. but
anyway moving on so what we've got going
on here both scripts are actually
identical um
they
import system import time just so we can
see it with enough time and then you can
see all it does is print out the system
version but i will show you guys that if
we go let's say we go f5 to run
uh
we're actually running in three three
because idle wants to default to three
three since that's the last one we
downloaded
um and changing that is possible and i
will show you guys how uh in a minute
but first i want to show you this um so
it's still gonna run in three three and
just for anyone that's curious um
this print like functionality you can do
this in python two seven
uh so even though this did run indeed in
three three you're able to do this like
the add the parentheses like this uh
into seven so just just for anybody
that's like well that's the three three
way of doing it anyway uh they're
identical and all they're going to do is
just print the version of python so what
i'm going to go ahead and do now is
close them both and the only difference
between these two scripts is just what
we call up here and this one just says
hey i want to run in python 2. this one
says hey i want to run in python 3. and
actually this is not necessary since we
downloaded python 3 last
i believe the default will be python 3
but now that i think about it i'm not
positive on that but anyways um in fact
let's just run another one i'm pretty
sure it's python 3 but now i can't
remember
i'll just run i'll edit this one and
just not have that
okay so uh
let's go ahead and we'll run this first
one okay yeah so so the default um is
actually two seven if you have both
installed interesting
um
so then it only makes sense that this 27
is gonna run too so let's hope so that
would be really bad so again we run this
one it is indeed running two seven and
if i ran this one it is indeed running
three three so that's how you would do
that now i imagine some of you guys are
like
how did you even get here like how did
you even get to make these scripts and
all that stuff right so so let's talk
about that let's say like how do we
actually do stuff like this but i did
just want to at least show some people
right off the bat how you can handle
having both versions so really in your
old versions you don't even really need
to put anything at the top because it's
going to default but just in case they
ever change that in the future you might
as well just keep it up there
so now um
what about all the the poor folk who
have never used python before so once
you've installed python
uh you should be able to at least go you
know to your directory and go to you
know python if you're on windows you
should be able to go to your start bar
or really any machine you should be able
to start bar and then go you know all
programs and at least for me uh mine's
gonna like i've seen python 27 and three
three here so since we used python 3 3
you should click on that and in fact let
me bring my
window down here
so here it is
3 3 and then here you have idle
module docs python command line
uninstall and manuals
um so the command line when you click on
that that's going to bring up kind of
like a live interpreter for you and so
what you can do is you can do stuff like
this like print um
hi right that's going to print out high
for you
and you can code straight in here but i
don't actually like doing it because it
is
uh it is live and so it's a little
tedious uh to use it because uh
it it's gonna work your program step by
step now in some senses like for
debugging purposes that could be useful
but also there's no easy way to save
this so really only for like really
short tests and stuff like that would i
recommend using this but the next thing
we'll come over to three three
and idle is what we want so there's
actually a lot of what's called ides
which is uh
your
and at least with with python they call
it idle it doesn't really matter it
isn't ide it's just interactive
development environment or it's like in
i think maybe it's integrated doesn't
really matter but it stands for the same
thing as every other ide stands for
python just added an l there it's just
for development
i'm pretty sure anyway so click on that
and that should bring up this bad boy
here and as you can see this says
python33
so
uh let me drag this window over now so
again if if you wanted to so i showed
you guys how to actually run the script
um
in
whatever version you want but check this
out if i right click here like generally
once you've installed python you should
have an edit with idle if we click on
that even though it's python27 right
that's the one we've wanted but if we
click on that and hit uh run
run module
it's actually as you can see at the top
here three three and it sure enough ran
in three three so that's kind of
annoying if you still want to develop in
python27 so the same way that we've
opened up the uh
the idle in python33 you can go here all
python27 idle and that'll bring up idle
for you let me just bring this back over
again though
and what you can do now is you can see
this is 2 7 and at the same time when
you go to open you can go file open
and we come over here and let's say i
want to open this one we've opened that
up now
and when i go to run you could even
close this if you wanted to or at least
you should be able to let's find out
yeah so you we opened it into seven and
so as you can see now we're actually
running into seven and you can do your
edits into seven so that's how you can
get around it because natively if you
edit with with idle now it's gonna be in
three three but anyway so i'm gonna
close out of this
and so so whenever you have a script
like you bring up idle the first time
like if you don't have any python files
you won't really have anything uh to
make but if you know don't have any
python files you would open up idle and
then go file new file
and you have this like untitled document
and so for now what i'll just say is
like you we'll
make it do something and so we'll just
put a print in here and it's just going
to print a space
and then what you want to do is you go
file save as
and then we'll bring it over here and
then for now i'll just say well we'll
call this tut
and
interestingly enough it looks like it
saves it as dot pi and two seven
whenever you like save an untitled
document in python it won't save it as
pi it'll save it as like i think it's
text
and or maybe even like no extension i
don't even know it's just really
annoying so i'm actually now i'm curious
because normally like you save it and it
saves it as all files and it's really
annoying so i'm going to hit save let's
find out
yes nice well in two seven
so if you are brand new to python and
some teachers making you use two seven
or two five when you go to save
originally you must add the dot pi at
the end otherwise it's going to save it
as like a blank text or like a regular
text file that's kind of annoying so i
see they fixed that in python 3 so
that's great
so
very long installation and you know how
to run all the various versions if you
want to
um but there are there's definitely a
ton of questions online about like how
to get that how to get both running at
the same time and generally if you're
gonna do python right at least at the
moment there's gonna be times where you
might need python27
so that's how you can do it that's how
you can get yourself all set up and now
you're ready to learn to program
so
uh anyways that's going to conclude the
installation and you know initial
setting up of everything
as always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions and
until next time